vamos a generalizar lo que vimos en el
vídeo pasado primero teníamos dos ejes
en el primer eje el eje vertical es el
eje de la siesta y voy a hacer un eje un
poco más horizontal que va a ser el eje
de las equis y en el vídeo pasado
tomábamos dos funciones entonces voy a
hacer la gráfica de mi primer función
esta de verde va a ser mi primer función
y va a ser algo así no importa pero lo
que importa es que tiene de nombre que
es igual a efe de x mientras que por
otro lado tomábamos otra función es este
azul que estoy dibujando aquí si la
nombramos en forma general va a ser que
es igual a gd x bonito nombre no creen
que iguala x y ya con esto tenemos a las
dos funciones generalizadas con sus
respectivos nombres ya que teníamos las
dos funciones la pregunta era cómo
encontrábamos el volumen del sólido de
revolución que obteníamos de girar esta
área en medio de estas dos funciones
alrededor del eje de las x es decir esta
área que está en medio de estas dos
funciones la vamos a girar alrededor del
eje de las x
y vamos a obtener una figura muy
parecida a esta recuerden que en el
vídeo pasado era como un tazón como un
trofeo se acuerdan en el cual adentro
existía un cono en forma general tenemos
un área entre dos funciones que vamos a
girar alrededor del eje de las x
obteniendo así un sólido de revolución y
nos preguntábamos cuál era su volumen la
idea que utilizamos en el vídeo anterior
era muy parecido al método de los discos
pero si ustedes se acuerdan no era un
disco como tal era una arandela porque
una arandela pues fíjense bien lo que
nosotros hacíamos era tomar entre estas
dos funciones un pequeño rectángulo que
tenga un ancho muy pequeño se acuerdan
cuál era el grosor de este rectángulo
pues claro era de x lo que queremos es
que sea un grosor muy muy muy delgado y
bueno la idea que teníamos detrás de
todo esto era girar este pequeño
rectángulo alrededor del eje de las
equis y por lo tanto se dan cuenta no me
sale un disco como tal me queda una
arandela fíjense esta es la parte de
adentro voy a dibujarla y esta es la
parte de afuera voy a intentar dibujarla
lo mejor que se pueda
que ustedes vean que en efecto tiene una
forma de arandela esta va a ser la parte
de afuera la parte exterior esta es la
parte interior y ahora voy a dibujar la
cara de esta grande la fíjense bien este
de aquí es mi cara de mi arandela la
estoy dibujando bastante bien bien va
bien y necesitamos también un grosor se
acuerdan entonces tenemos el grosor de x
este que estoy dibujando aquí es un
cierto grosor fíjense bien que ya está
agarrando un poco de volumen por lo
tanto lo podemos visualizar como si
tuviéramos una moneda en la cual se le
quita la parte de en medio es decir una
arandela muy bien ya la estoy dibujando
aquí y creo que no me quedó nada mal
imagina sea una moneda que está
agujereada por el centro y bueno para
sacar el volumen del sólido de
revolución
lo que queremos primero es el volumen de
esta arandela pero antes que el volumen
sería muy bueno calcular primero el área
es decir el área de la cara que tenemos
aquí y que es el área lo primero que
vamos a hacer es sacar el área de esta
moneda como si no tuviera agujero es
decir sacar el área de esta
circunferencia con la función superior
esto quiere decir que spears
el radio al cuadrado pero el radio es la
función exterior y por lo tanto me queda
pi que multiplica a fx elevada al
cuadrado esta es el área de toda la
moneda ahora a esta moneda le voy a
quitar el centro es decir le voy a
quitar el área que se forma cuando yo
giro la función inferior alrededor del
eje das equis y como es una
circunferencia también me va a quedar pi
que multiplica al radio al cuadrado pero
en este caso el radio es la función
inferior por lo tanto me queda pi que
multiplica a la función inferior que en
este caso era de equis pero como es el
radio del cuadrado hay que elevarla
también al cuadrado es decir pi por el
radio que es gd x elevado al cuadrado lo
único que estoy haciendo es sacando el
área del agujero que tenemos en la
moneda porque qué creés justo el área
que estoy buscando es la diferencia
entre estas dos áreas es decir con esto
ya saqué el área de la arandela fíjense
que aquí ya tengo una función arriba y
una función abajo es decir una función
superior y una función inferior y
haciendo esto estoy sacando el área de
esta arandela ese factor y si me queda
que el área es igual a pi que multiplica
quién
una parte a efe x elevado al cuadrado
pero dejan de escribir lo mejor de esta
manera f x elevado al cuadrado menos gtx
elevado al cuadrado y así me ahorro un
paréntesis entonces ya tengo por fin
déjenme ponerlo con amarillo para que
quede más ordenado todo esto y ya con
esta expresión tengo el área de la cara
que tenemos de la arandela si yo quiero
el volumen hay que multiplicar todo esto
por el grosor pero el grosor era de x
por lo tanto me queda pi por fx elevado
al cuadrado menos gtx elevado al
cuadrado y todo esto lo voy a
multiplicar por el grosor para sacar el
volumen entonces todo esto lo
multiplicamos por de x y así obtengo el
volumen de una arandela de esta grande
la que tengo dibujada aquí pero como
nosotros queremos la suma de todas las
arandelas que están entre estas dos
funciones lo que tengo que hacer es
tomarme la suma de todos estos volúmenes
y hacer que de x sea muy pequeño es
decir tomar el límite cuando de x es muy
pequeño para tomar una infinidad de
arandelas las cuales van a ser muy
delgadas y por lo tanto voy a obtener la
integral sin embargo es una integral
definida definida entre qué puntos y
bueno pues podemos tomar dos puntos
arbitraria
y pueden ser los puntos de la
intersección de estas dos funciones o
pueden ser que no sean la intersección
de estas dos funciones sin embargo para
verlo de una manera general voy a decir
que la integral es de ave de toda esta
expresión que yo tengo aquí es decir del
volumen de las arandelas y recuerdan que
detrás traigo la suma de todas los
volúmenes de todas las arandelas y el
límite cuando de x es muy pequeño es
decir las arandelas son muy delgadas y
bueno para probar esta expresión que
acabamos de encontrar vamos a echar la
andar con las mismas funciones que vimos
en el vídeo pasado si se acuerdan en el
caso pasado gtx era igual a x mientras
que f x era igual a la raíz cuadrada de
x entonces vamos a meterlas en esta
nueva fórmula que acabamos de encontrar
para ver si funciona entonces el volumen
es igual a la integral y se acuerdan los
puntos donde se interceptaban estas dos
funciones eran entre 0 y 1
recuerden que podemos tomar cualquier
intervalo pero en esta ocasión me voy a
tomar el intervalo en donde se
interceptaban estas dos funciones que da
el intervalo de 0 hasta 11 es lo mismo
que la raíz cuadrada positiva de 1 por
lo tanto estas dos funciones en esos dos
puntos son iguales
de quien de piqué multiplica a fx
elevado al cuadrado pero la raíz de x
elevada al cuadrado pues es lo mismo que
x menos gtx elevado al cuadrado es decir
gx es x elevado al cuadrado me queda x
cuadrada y todo esto lo voy a
multiplicar por de x que es el grosor y
bien ahora que ya tengo esto voy a sacar
primero a piqué es la constante y me
queda pi que multiplica el integral de
cero a uno de x men x cuadrada de x y
ahora sí busquemos las anti derivadas la
anti derivada de x x cuadrado entre 2
esto está muy sencillo menos la anti
derivada de x cuadrada que es x cúbica
entre 3 le sumamos en el exponente y lo
dividimos entre este mismo número y esto
evaluado de 0 a 1 así que vamos a hacer
la evaluación me queda que es lo mismo
que piqué va a multiplicar déjenme
ponerlo aquí esto va a ser lo mismo que
problemas de espacio pero ya ese espacio
esto va a ser lo mismo que pi que
multiplica a bueno me queda uno elevado
al cuadrado entre 2 es lo mismo que un
medio menos uno elevado al cubo entre 3
que es lo mismo que un tercio entonces
me queda un medio menos un tercio y
después si yo evalúan 0 me queda 0 al
cuadrado
200 entre 30 es decir todo esto evaluado
en 0 se va no es necesario ponerlo y
solamente me queda un medio menos un
tercio y que creen un medio menos un
tercio fue justo lo que hicimos en el
vídeo pasado esto de aquí es lo mismo
que un sexto y por lo tanto obtuve el
mismo resultado es lo mismo que pitt
sextos de unidades de área y que cree no
obtuve lo mismo que en el vídeo pasado y
es que la razón de que llegamos a lo
mismo es que esta es la fórmula ya
generalizada de lo que vimos en el
ejemplo anterior lo que logré en este
ejercicio fue que este método de las
arandelas generaliza el volumen de los
sólidos de revolución que hay al girar
el área entre dos funciones alrededor
del eje de las x así que nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo